[Musica]
[Applauso]
aspettiamo un bambino ci diciamo come
sarà sarà maschio sarà femmina
abbiamo dei sogni delle paure
ci chiediamo sarà vera quella cosa che
salta una generazione non è che poi
assomiglia a tua madre e e se una
femmina ea le mie gambe
no abbiamo di queste preoccupazioni ma
ci prendiamo anche dei seri impegni con
noi stessi come futuri genitori
tra le cose che ci diciamo ci sono
alcune che sappiamo non contraddire mo
mai una di queste che nostro figlio o
nostra figlia
imparerà a suonare almeno uno strumento
sì perché a lui oa lei non capiterà come
succede a me ogni volta che vado ad un
concerto di sentire quell'imbarazzo e
quella vergogna per aver abbandonato il
sassofono se solo i miei mi avessero
obbligato a continuarlo a e poi farà
sport
mens sana in corpore sano e poi è un
ambiente e un ambiente sano per crescere
di sani valori dove imparare tante di
quelle cose che servono e che la scuola
non ti può dare e saprà almeno una
lingua straniera fin da piccolo perché
si sa che se no non si riesce a prendere
l'accento per davvero se si impara la
lingua straniera da grandi come è
successo a me prendiamo anche degli
altri impegni ci diciamo cosa non faremo
non saremo come i nostri genitori
noi saremo speciali in italia in questo
momento un genitore su 88
qualche anno dopo aver fatto questi
pensieri si sente effettivamente
definire speciale ma con un'accezione
completamente diversa sarà un dottore un
neuropsichiatra infantile o uno
psicologo a dirglielo
gli dirà sei un genitore speciale lo
sarai per tutta la vita perché tuo
figlio o tua figlia avrà per tutta la
vita dei bisogni speciali
tuo figlio o tua figlia all'autismo
lavoro con persone che si sono sentite
dare questo tipo di notizia di solito mi
viene raccontato di una mamma che dopo
un anno di vita del suo bambino della
sua bambina
inizia ad avere delle brutte sensazioni
ha l'impressione che il linguaggio che
sta emergendo regredisca che il gioco
che sta emergendo non funzioni come
dovrebbe
c'è qualcosa che non va che non sa
spiegare e se ne parla con qualcuno
le viene detto porta pazienza
6 ansiosa se lo dice con un pediatra
facilmente verrà puntato il dito verso
di lei e le verrà ricordato signora i
maschietti parlano dopo due anni dopo
questa mamma che sta prendendo pillole
per l'ansia pillole per la depressione
pillole per dormire scopre che aveva
ragione sente cosa le dicono ma non lo
ascolta
si chiama shock e questa mamma non ha
neanche il lusso che hanno gli altri che
devono rinunciare a un progetto di vita
a qualcuno oa qualcosa
il lusso di attraversare quelle che
chiamiamo le fasi del lutto perché
quello stesso giorno il giorno in cui le
viene detto autismo lei dovrà prendere
delle decisioni
scegliere il dottore scegliere la
terapia trovare i soldi per fare la
terapia tre anni fa me lo ricordo ancora
perché ricordo che ho pensato che carini
si sono fatti belli pervenire dalla
dottoressa ricordo questi due genitori
che sono venuti nel mio studio la loro
bambina era stata diagnosticata di
autismo un anno prima
e io ero il ventesimo professionista da
cui si recavano avendo girato tutta
l'italia tra centri esperti e avendo
studiato tutto quello che si poteva
trovare su internet e in libreria
ho chiesto loro di raccontarmi la loro
quotidianità e mi hanno descritto quella
che è un po la storia di tutti o di
molti mi hanno detto che la loro bambina
che all'inizio parlava un po aveva
smesso di parlare che non li guardava
negli occhi si chiamavano il suo nome
non girava neanche più la testa
che non giocava con gli altri bambini
preferiva allineare sempre il solito
giocattolo e reagiva molto male
piangendo in modo isterico e difficile
da interrompere se qualcuno si inframed
eva tra lei e il suo gioco
mangiava un solo cibo e non si riusciva
a darle più nient'altro da mangiare e si
svegliava tra le 6 e le 7 volte ogni
notte ho fatto alcune domande in quel
momento perché mi sono chiesta se
saranno sbagliati staranno esagerando e
mi sono informata su come si
organizzassero avevano tutto un piano
per dormire circa quattro ore a testa
ogni notte ho cominciato a chiedermi
assieme al mio gruppo di ricerca non
soltanto per loro ma anche per tutti gli
altri come loro
come fanno queste persone a reggersi in
piedi
questi chiodi fronte a me come hanno
guidato in sicurezza fino al mio studio
come possono raccontarmi una storia con
un inizio e una fine una storia che ha
perfettamente senso che è un filo logico
come fanno in quegli anni non era
soltanto il mio gruppo di ricerca a
farsi queste domande ma sono usciti i
primi studi che hanno realmente misurato
a quale tipo di stress e sottoposta alla
famiglia di una persona con autismo si è
trovato che una sola categoria di esseri
umani sopravviveva la quantità di stress
a cui è sottoposta la mamma di un
bambino con autismo ed erano i militari
in guerra
di più qualcosa di particolare da dire
sulle mamme delle persone con autismo
dagli anni ottanta in tutto il mondo si
è diffusa una teoria suggestiva che
state di seguito completamente
invalidata dalla ricerca è che tuttavia
per la suggestione che ha portato in
tutto il mondo e ancora qualcosa che si
sente dire
e ancora qualcosa in cui qualcuno crede
talvolta i genitori stessi si parlava di
madri frigorifero si riteneva che
fossero i genitori i colpevoli
dell'autismo dei figli negli stati uniti
si allontanavano i figli dai genitori
come terapia in europa a partire dagli
anni 80 e per quasi un ventennio
le mamme dei bambini con autismo come
cura per i loro figli sono state mandate
in psicanalisi o in psicoterapia a
cercare dentro di sé le cause di quella
freddezza primordiale di quel rifiuto
inconscio chi era la causa secondo
questa teoria dell'autismo dei figli
questa abitudine a puntare il dito sui
genitori è qualcosa che attecchisce sul
genitore stesso perché resta in lui o in
lei una domanda assurda inespressa
che cosa ho fatto forse di sbagliato
andava tutto bene e poi non andava più
che sia io che si ha dentro di me il
problema nella mia carne nei miei
visceri nei miei geni questa
per noi ricercatori e la generazione in
cui abbiamo la gioia e la soddisfazione
di partecipare alla rivincita dei
genitori di persone con autismo perché
sappiamo che in quella manciata di anni
in cui dalla diagnosi alla ricerca di
cure studiano libri fanno corsi e
diventano esperti di quelle che si
chiamano le autonomie di vita
in quegli anni fanno come un corso
accelerato di genitorialità qualcosa che
è per tutti gli altri è un percorso per
cui non sempre basta una vita intera per
raggiungere le stesse consapevolezze il
genitore di una persona con auto con
autismo in pochissimi anni raggiunge
consapevolezza che di solito ci possono
raccontare soltanto i nonni persone che
la vita l'hanno già vissuta tutta e che
i problemi li hanno visti accadere
talvolta risolversi e talvolta no
ecco le cinque consapevolezze del
genitore di un bambino con autismo che
oggi può insegnare a ognuno di noi
la prima è che tuo figlio non è il tuo
prodotto che pensavi fosse tuo
appartiene a se stesso e al mondo
la seconda è che non sarà la persona che
avevi progettato all'inizio non lo puoi
progettare la terza è che qualunque
siano i principi e le decisioni assolute
e i patti che avevi fatto con te stesso
all'inizio già dal concepimento
tu non potrai seguirli non dovrai
seguirli tu dovrai cambiare il miglior
genitore possibile è quello che non sa
già cosa avrebbe fatto ma lo decide
osservando i bisogni del suo bambino
della sua bambina e cambiando
la sua strategia mentre questo cresce la
quarta di queste consapevolezze e che
dando la stessa opportunità ha due figli
diversi otterremo dei risultati diversi
non siamo degli architetti della vita
dei nostri figli
infine è vero che cresciamo un figlio
che è nostro ma la miglior cosa la più
utile che possiamo fare fin da quando è
piccolo e aiutarlo a diventare autonomo
perché un giorno sarà solo e la vita
sarà sua
con questo vi sto invitando se doveste
avere in futuro delle domande concrete
difficili da porgere a qualcuno di
esperto certamente potrete venire dagli
psicologi come me ma potrete anche
chiedere al genitore di una persona con
autismo
loro lo sanno e lo sanno prima di tutti
grazie
[Applauso]